now performing loved from his album when
a croner dies which is out today
everybody give it up for Leslie Odum
Jr show you've loved show how I love
you you came to sing a song they just
came to record
you oh ring me dry ring me dry pour out
all the water from inside oh let shine
through show you've been Lov show them
how i l
[Music]
you with me my son then go rest your
head sing our favorite songs the ones we
sang
back what's a memory for if we let him
die live forever in love that's always
alive these Ain tears the raindrops from
answered
prayers life is eyink we cry then Joy
your eyes never Li let see
show
show you came to sing a song faes came
to record
you oh ring me dry ring me dry pour out
all the water thrown
inside Let It Shine through show you
show I love
you
show me I don't to be a
h let meal Shad I'm
again
all I give is this hope one day at a
time all I see is
this
I I
am life is an eye blink we cry then we
leave joy in your eyes never lies let
him see show youve love show them how I
love you
you came sing a song they just came to
record
you oh ring me dry ring me dry all the
water from
inside Let It Shine through show you've
been Lov show how I love
you show
[Music]
you
wow so beautiful oh my gosh once more
let's hear it for Leslie odm
J today we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home